i cut out everything i thought could be  causing inflammation in my body all  grains sugar processed foods soy dairy  eggs shellfish anything that people are  commonly allergic to or that i had heard  somewhere could cause inflammation i  lost five pounds which wasn't a lot but  i went down three pant sizes and so i  had bloating that i hadn't noticed i'd  had disappeared but more importantly  this blistering rash which was awful it  healed for the first time in almost a  year and a half and then the pain in my  shoulders when i was sleeping went away  and that was within the first month of  eliminating a lot of these foods from my  diet then i really got interested in  this